maroon 5 is practically
elevator music at this point so i'm sure
you know who adam levine is
um
but adam and i were seeing each other
for about a year
instagram model sumner stro's cheating
allegation against adam levine has blown
up online
and now a source explains to e.t how the
singer and his wife biati prinzloo are
navigating the scandal the real you no
matter what like it or not the real use
coming out
no matter how close you play your cards
you better just embrace it we're told
like most couples adam and biati have
had their ups and downs the source says
while adam admits he crossed the line he
also maintains he never physically
cheated
quote he's telling biati and his friends
that although someone claimed there was
a physical relationship it never
happened
the source adds that adam loves
attention from women and crossed a
boundary but he's telling his wife it
will never happen again
i'd say a lot of things you know and
some some things i stand by and some
things i
you know put my foot in my mouth a
little bit
yeah and that's kind of how all this
drama unfolded
earlier this week sumner dropped this
now viral tick-tock video which showed
alleged flirtatious dms between her and
adam essentially
i was having an affair with a man who's
married to a victory secret model at the
time you know i was
young i was naive and
i mean quite frankly i feel exploited i
wasn't in the scene like i am now um so
i was definitely very easily manipulated
and adam he didn't stay quiet about it
for long
a day later the maroon 5 frontman
responded to sumner's claims in a
statement on his instagram story
posting in part quote i used poor
judgment in speaking with anyone other
than my wife in any kind of flirtatious
manner i did not have an affair
nevertheless i crossed the line during a
regrettable period in my life
as for why adam responded to the claims
well a separate source tells e.t the
rocker wanted to speak out as soon as
possible to avoid any stories getting
out of hand
quote he wanted to confront everything
head-on and address things right away
it's tough with with life happening and
things work and you know
everything going on to always find that
time but i i think we've
we've set a pretty high standard for us
as a couple individual the two of us
aside from the kids and family and all
of that to really just
make sure we're good and one if we're
good the kids are good our families are
good so we're just a good team and that
good teamwork was on full display
tuesday
adam and biati were spotted out in
montecito seemingly in good spirits and
putting on a united front
our source says adam's embarrassed and
recognizes that his actions were
inappropriate
and now he's trying to make things right
with biati and his family
[Music]
you